[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا ميسون نواهد احييكم
وهذه العربيه
360 الخبر من كل زواياه هو من جميع جوانبه
نبدا بالعناوين
ز
تتواصل بعد انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي
شنطن تبيعوا استراليا خمس غواصات تعمل
بالدفع النوويه واتفاق ثلاثيه يجمعهما مع
لندن لبناء جيل جديد
يتم ايداع الايرادات الكليه
للنفط المنتج من حقول وتقولين في حساب
سوداني يعلن اتفاقا لافتا مع اربيل يجمع
ايرادات نقطه كردستان في حساب واحد ويتيح
للاقليم مراقبته
النفط الخام
ولدينا ايضا في 360
[تصفيق]
الاوسكري يغير جلده
على نهج السرد التقليدي والهند وماليزيا
تلامسان حلما
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تواعد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
بمحاسبه المتسببين بانهيار بنك سيليكون
فالي وقال ان لا احد فوق القانون كما اكد
بايدن ان النظام المصرفي الامريكي امن
وبامكان المذيعين الوصول لاموالهم دون
عوائق
اليوم وجهت الاداره بالتحرك سريعا لاحتواء
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي بامكان
المودعين الوصول الى اموالهم بدون عوائق
المستثمرون الذين يخاطرون بودائع
الامريكيين ستتم محاسبتهم ولن تكون هناك
حمايه لاصحاب قرارات المخاطر التي ادت
لهذه الازمه ولن نسمح بتكرار اخفاقات
البنوك وسنعمل على حمايه الشركات الناشئه
اريد التاكيد على ان دافعي الضرائب لن
يتحملوا اي خسائر بسبب ازمه البنوك
في الاثناء حذر الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب بشده من تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون
فالي والقت ترامب باللومه على السياسات
الاقتصاديه لبايدن مشيرا الى ان المزيد من
الكوارث الاقتصاديه تلوح في الافق بسبب
وضع الاقتصاد ومقترحات زياده نسب الضرائب
قال مفوض الاقتصاد في الاتحاد الاوروبي
باولو ان انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي لا يشكل
تهديدا خطيرا لاوروبا لكنه اضاف انه تجب
مراقبه احتمال حدوث تاثير غير مباشر
مستبعدا في الوقت ذاته انتقال العدوى الى
القاره العجوز
ولمتابعه هذه التطورات في الاسواق
الامريكيه وما هي ايضا التعاملات الحاليه
دائما نذهب الى قسم الاقتصاد في العربيه
والليله مع لاردلي لارا ماذا لدينا من
جديد حول سيليكون فالي شكرا لك ميسون اذا
الامر الملفت ميسون انه بعد ان افتتحت
الاسواق الامريكيه على تراجعات قويه الوضع
اختلف الان تماما الان عم نتحدث عن
ارتفاعات قويه في الاسواق الامريكيه
الاسهم في بدا الجلسه على تراجع بسته
باكثر من واحد بالمئه الان اصبح مرتفع
بسته اعشار بالمئه الناس ارتفاعات بواحد
فاصل 7% دعونا نتوقف عند اسباب التحول في
اداء الاسواق الامريكيه الان الرهان في
الاسواق انه في ظل ازمه المصارف الفيدرالي
سوف يضطر لتغيير من سياسته النقديه وربما
سوف يضطر لابطاء وتيره رفع الفائده حتى
بعد البنوك عم
كان ايضا يفرض على البنوك الاصغر ولكن في
العام 2018 تم تخفيف هذه القيود على
البنوك الاصغر لذلك الان ظهرت هذه المشاكل
بالبنوك الاصغر البنوك الاكبر مع منشوف
فيها تراجعات التي سجلت بالبنوك الاصغر
اليوم ولو انه فيها خسائر سيتي جروب سته
ولكن فكره اليوم بنوك الاصغر مثل كان فيه
تراجعات وصلت الى 80
كان فيه تراجعات بستين بالمئه
وصلت الخسائر تقريبا ولو انه تم وقف
التداول على هذه المصارف والان تراجعت
الخسائر عليها
في هذه الساعه اذا هذه الصوره في الاسواق
الامريكيه الاسواق الاوروبيه اغلقت اليوم
على تراجعات ايضا بقياده القطاع المصري في
رغم التطمينات اللي سمعناها منذ قليل من
المفوضيه الاوروبيه من الجهات التنظيميه
حتى من المحللين اللي عم بيقولوا انه
الوضع في القطاع المصري في الاوروبي مختلف
عن هذه البنوك الصغرى في الولايات المتحده
الا ان راينا تراجعات حاده اليوم كريدي
سويس مستويات متدنيه تاريخيه بنوك اخرى
كوميرس بنك 13% من التراجع سته
من التراجع ماذا عن الاصول الاخرى اليوم
ما في شهيه لاخذ المخاطر عم نشوف لجوء
للملذات الامنه هذا عم يرفع اسعار السندات
بنفس الوقت عم يؤدي الى تراجعات كبيره على
عوائد السندات نظرا للعلاقه العكسيه بين
اسعار السندات وعوائدها اليوم عائد
السنتين كان كسر نزولا حاجز الاربعه
بالمئه ولكن الان يعود الى فوق هذه
المستويات ولكن لاحظوا التراجعات 11% من
الخسائر نفس الصوره شفناها بعوائد سندات
الاوروبيه عوائد الالمانيه اليوم كان فيها
تراجعات حاده العوائد البريطانيه ايضا
سجلت تراجعات قويه من اخرى الذهب عم بيسجل
ارتفاع كونه ملاذ امن الامر الملفت ايضا
الذهب هو مرتفع باثنين بالمئه الامر
الملفت ايضا انه البيتكوين يلي عاده
المفروض تكون اصل عالي المخاطر وهلا لاخذ
المخاطر اليوم العملات الرقميه عم بتسجل
الارتفاع والبيتكوين عم بتسجل الارتفاع 13
بالمئه لانه
يعني في ظل التوقعات بانه ممكن ان نرى
تخفيفي وتيره رفع الفائده في الولايات
المتحده اليوم في اجتماع استثنائي
للفدرالي لم تصدر عليه بعد اي اخبار هو
اجتماع مغلق للفدرالي الامريكي
والاجتماع المقرر هو في الثاني والعشرين
من فبراير يجب الاشاره اخيرا مشاهدينا انه
تطرقنا الى موضوع رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
وضح بالتصريحات فقط المودعين في هذه
البنوك المتعثره لثلاث بنوك المتعثره هم
المحميين يلي سوف
يعاد اليهم الاموال وليس المساهمين وليس
دائمين هذه البنوك بالتالي الان نسمع انه
مساهموه البنك سلك فالي رفعوا دعوه جماعيه
ضد البيت ضد الشركه الام للبنك وضد الرئيس
المالي والرئيس التنفيذي لانه اخفوا
الخسائر المحتمله من جراء وتاثر البنك من
جراء ارتفاع اسعار الفائده نذكر هنا بانه
الرئيس المالي او الرئيس التنفيذي
لسيليكون فالي ثلاثه اخبار انه قبل فتره
قبل ايام قليله باع جزء من حصته في البنك
كانت على ما اظن على ما اذكر فوق المليوني
دولار على كل مشاهدينا اذا الوضع اصبح
افضل باسواق الاسهم الامريكيه قبل ان نختم
نظره سريعه على اسعار النفط التي تسجل
تراجعات اليوم اليوم براند كان [__] ر
مستويات ال80 دولار ولكن يعود فوق هذه
المستويات اكيد اي اشارات حول وجود ازمه
ماليه هذا ببطء من
الحركه الاقتصاديه وبالتالي ممكن ان يؤثر
على الطلب على النفط لذلك عم نشوف هذه
التراجعات اليوم التي كانت اكبر على اسعار
النفط مشاهدينا نحن بكون معكم لمتابعه اي
جديد عن هذه الازمه ولكن الان نعود الى
زميله ميسون لمتابعه نشره الاخبار
اجراءات عده اتخذتها وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه بالتشاوري مع الرئيس جو بايدن
ومع البنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لتجنب
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي ولتمكين
المودعين من الحصول على اموالهم
اكرر لا خسائر سيتحملها دافع والضرائب من
اهم ما اكد عليه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
خلال كلمته هو ان جميع اموال المودعين
ودافعي الضرائب في البنوك مؤمنه ويمكن
الحصول عليها من دون عائق وطلب من
الامريكيين الثقه في النظام المصرفي فقبل
هذه الازمه كانت الحكومه الفيدراليه تضمن
من خلال المؤسسه الفيدراليه للتامين على
الودائع الودائع التي لا تزيد قيمتها عن
250 الف دولار
قاعده 250 الف دولار ستستمر ولن تتراجع
الحكومه عنها السبب الوحيد لتعليقها
للبنكين منع العدوى الماليه لكن الحكومه
ستغير بعض اللوائح في المستقبل لمحاوله
الحد من اي خطر معنوي ربما يكون قد تسببوا
فيه عبر اقتراح ان الحكومه ستتدخل دائما
لانقاذ المودعين لكن الوضع بالنسبه
للمستثمرين الذين يخاطرون بودائع
الامريكيين مختلف وفق بايدن لانهم لن
يحظوا باي حمايه فيما تعهد بمحاسبه
المسؤولين عن ازمه البنوك معتبرا ان لا
احد فوق القانون
سيتم طرد اداره هذه البنوك اذا تم
الاستيلاء على البنك من قبل المؤسسه
الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع فيجب على
الاشخاص الذين يديرون البنك الا يعملوا
هناك بعد الان
بيضا وعد بان الاجراءات لحمايه المودعين
ولعدم تكرار اخفاقات البنوك ستستمر الى ان
تنتهي ازمه مصرفي سيليكون
فيما سيطلب من الكونجرس تجديد القوانين
المتعلقه بالبنوك حسين الطوط العربيه
واشنطن
قالت ان اداره الرئيس بايدن ستوافق رسميا
اليوم على مشروع كبير للتنقيب عن نفط
ولايه الاسكا رغم المعارضه الواسعه
للمشروع بسبب اثاره المحتمله على البيئه
في المقابل سيفرض بايدن قيودا على التنقيب
على النفط البحري في القطب الشمالي في
محاوله للحد من الانتقال بل من الانتقادات
لقراره حول مشروع ويلو
مشروع ولو الذي يتوقع مشاهدينا موافقه
الاداره الامريكيه عليه يقع شمال غرب
ولايه الاسكا الامريكيه تكلفه هذا المشروع
ستصل عند اكتماله الى نحو ثمانيه مليار
دولار امريكي بقياده شركه النفط العملاقه
كونوكو فيليبس القدره الانتاجيه من
المفترض ان تزيد بحسب تقديرات عن 600
مليون برميل من النفط الخام على مدار 30
عاما كما نتابع في هذه الصوره خلفيه وهذا
الرقم هو اساس يومي يعني انتاج 180 الف
برميل من النفط مؤيد المشروع يرون انه
يوجد واقتصاديه كبيره لسكان المنطقه
بتوفير
2500 فرصه عمل كما انه سيضيف للخزينه
الامريكيه ما يصل الى 17 مليار دولار من
العائدات سيضيفها الحكومه على الجانب
الاخر يتحدث المنتقدون عن ان التنقيب
سيؤدي الى اطلاق ما يقرب من 280 مليون طن
من انبعاثات الكربون في الغلاف الجوي
سنويا وهو ما يعادل اضافه مليون سياره الى
الطرق الامريكيه كل عاما اذا مشاهدينا
نبقى مع منتقديه مشروع ويلو والجماعات
المدافعه عن البيئه مجموعه العمل البيئي
ارث جستس بدات اجراءات رفع دعوه ضد
الاداره الامريكيه بحجه ان سلطه بايدن
لحمايه الموارد على الاراضي العامه في
الاسكا تتضمن اتخاذ خطوات للحد من
انبعاثات الكربون كما جادلت مجموعات بيئيه
وقسم من سكان الاسكا الاصليين بان المشروع
سيضر باهداف الرئيس المناخيه طموحه اضافه
لتشكيله اخطارا صحيه وبيئيه
ايضا بدا عشرات الالاف بتوجيه رسائل
مكتوبه وعرائد الكترونيه للبيت الابيض
للمطالبه بعدم الموافقه على المشروع اما
نائب الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق الجار فاعتبر
ان قرار الاداره سيعد متهورا وغير مسؤوله
واعتبر الجار ان مشروعه ويلو سيكون بمثابه
قنبله بيئيه بالنسبه لالسكا
في العربيه 360 نتابع بعد قليل تقرير اممي
يلوم الامم المتحده والنظام السوري على
تاخر وصول المساعدات للمتضر الزلزال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيكس ان امريكا كانت على تواصل
مع السعوديه خلال محادثتها مع ايران واضاف
سالبا ان الاتفاق السعودي الايراني ايجابي
لوقف تصعيد التوترات في المنطقه مشيرا الى
ان الولايات المتحده ليست في وضع ما يسمح
لها بالوساطه بين البلدين قال ان امريكا
مستمره في التواصل مع ايران لكن لا يوجد
اتفاق بشان تبادل سجناء حاليا في سياق اخر
قال سوليفان ان البيت الابيض شجع الرئيس
الصيني على الحديث مع نظيره الاوكراني
مضيف ان بايدن سيتواصل مع الرئيس الصيني
قريبا لان امريكا تريد ان تكون علاقتها مع
الصين تنافسا وليس صراعا
افادت بان الرئيس الصيني تشيم بينك سيجتمع
بالرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير سيلينسكي عبر
تقنيه الفيديو لاول مره منذ الحرب وذلك
عقب نهايه زياره
كما رجحت الصحيفه ان يزور الرئيس الصيني
دولا اوروبيه بعد هذه الزياره
في الاثناء انتقد المتحدث باسم الاتحاد
الاوروبي للشؤون الخارجيه والسياسيه
والامنيه بيترستانو مقترح الصين للحل في
اوكرانيا واعتبر ان موقف بكين اظهر
انحيازها الى جانب واحد في هذا الصراع
لانها ترفض تحديدا من هو المعتدي ومن هو
الضحيه على حد وصفه
والى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا في حديث
جمعه مع الرئيس بوتين نقاله رئيس جمهوريه
الشيشان رمضان قديروف ان مقاتلي جمهوريته
ينفذون الاوامر العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وانهم مستمرون حتى النهايه
قاتل جمهوريه الشيشان يخدمون بنجاح في
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا نحن
نفي بجميع اوامركم ونهدف الى الاستمرار
حتى نهايه المنتصره
على الجانب الاخر تتسارع عمليات تدريب
القوات الاوكرانيه في عدد من البلدان
الاوروبيه كابولندا والمانيا واسبانيا على
دبابات اثنين الالمانيه والتي يامل الغرب
ان تغير مجرى المعارك في عده جبهات مشتعله
يتدربون اثنتي عشره ساعه في اليوم لسته
ايام في الاسبوع يصارعون عدوهم الاول
الوقت يطوعون ثلاثه اشهر من التدريب
الالزامي في خمسه او ثمانيه اسابيع كحد
اقصى ويعيدون بناء جيش قادرا على استعمال
الات الحرب الحديثه فعشرون بالمئه فقط من
الجيش الاوكراني قادر على التعامل مع
الدبابات الحربيه في ساعات الصباح الاولى
يبدا الجنود الاوكراني التدريب في مركز
سان جورجو العسكري في زيرا جوزا شرقيه
اسبانيا حوالي 55 جنديا يتدربون على قطع
تحاكي العمل على الدبابات الحقيقيه قبل
خروجهم الى معسكرات التدريب تتطلب دبابه
ليوبارد الواحده طاقم من يتكون من اربعه
جنود لتشغيلها بالمقابل فهي تقدم مميزات
عده تجعل قرار ارسال مئات الجنود الاوكران
للتدريب في خضم الحرب قرارا مهما ويعد
مدفع دبابات ليو بورد اثنان من اهم
الميزات الموجوده فيها اذ يمتلك قدره ثبات
عاليه على الاراضي غير المستويه بسرعه 70
كم مدعوم بنظام تحكم رقمي ميزه تفتقر لها
الدبابات الاوكرانيه التي تعود لعهد
الاتحاد السوفيتي كما ان مقدمه الدبابه
مدعومه بصفائح مضاده للالغام ميزه اخرى
امام الالغام الروسيه الذكيه التي تقفز من
مكانها لاقتناص الدبابات الاوكرانيه
يظل تحدي الاكبر هو امكانيه توظيف
التدريبات المكثفه التي تلقاها الجنود في
ميدان المعارك المشتعله الذي سيكون الحسم
في رهان الغربي على هذه الدبابات كرم
حناوي العربيه
من القاهره ينضم الينا احمد عليبه الباحث
في وحده الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في
مركز الاهرام لدراسه السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه السيد عليبا اهلا بكم معنا
الى اي مدى هذه التدريبات التي يتلقاها
الجنود الاوكران خاصه على
العديد من الاسلحه الغربيه الى اي حد هي
كافيه خاصه بان الوقت قليل يعني كما تسمى
ان تنسف يعني من ثلاثه اشهر يوصلونها الى
ثلاثه اسابيع تمرينات
صحيح يعني هناك ضغط واضح في الميدان
بالنسبه للطلب على وجود هذه القوات التي
سوف يتم تدريبها بشكل نوعي لكن هذا لا
يعني ان يعني ستكون هناك فجوه بالعكس هناك
برنامج تدريب صحيح انه هو طويل الى حد ما
لكن هذا البرنامج مهم من اكثر من زاويه
زاويه الاولى انه نحن امام عمليه تحول من
قوات كانت عمليا تعمل وفقا نهج السوفيتي
او النهج الروسي قبل بدء هذه الحرب بعده
سنوات ربما منذ 2014 بدات بعد احتلال
روسيا القرن بدا يكون هناك تغير في بعض
البرامج لكن لم يكن بهذا المستوى الكبير
الان اصبح هناك نهج لتحويل هذا القوات الى
النظام الغربي او تحديدا نظام حلف الناتو
المساله الاخرى انه عمليه التدريب بتخضع
ليس فقط للاسلحه يعني سوف يكون هناك تدريب
مثلا على ليبرد سوف يكون هناك تدريب على
ايضا منظومه باتريوت في المرحله الحاليه
لكن الاهم هو التدريب على العمليات
المشتركه لانه كيف ستدار كل هذه المنظومات
الغربيه الجديده التي سوف تكون موجوده في
الساحه الاوكرانيه نحن امام تحاول كبير
كما ذكرت وبالتالي هذا التحول يفرض هذا
النوع من البرنامج
في هذه المرحله الى اي حد اثنين يعني كل
الامال تعقد عليها هل هي حقيقه قادره على
حسم المعارك على الارض ام لا يكفي فقط
التمرن والحصول على يوفرت 2 الالمانيه
هي لا تشكل قيمه مضافه مهمه بالنسبه
للجانب الاوكراني بالنسبه لها
باعتبار ان هي تقوم بمهام متعدده في حقيقه
الامر ما اقدرش ان انا اقارنها 72 لكن هي
مهمه في هذه الحاله بشكل او باخر في تطوير
العمليات لكن ده ايضا يتوقف على بقيه
المنظومات الاخرى ليس فقط المنظومات
الارضيه ولكن ايضا منظومات الجويه ما فيش
سلاح لوحده نقدر نقول ان هو هيحسم المعركه
بشكل مختلف هناك مجموعه من او خريطه تسلح
بتتم حاليا دلوقتي هذا الخريطه لما هتتشكل
مع بعضها في نهايه المطاف تقدر او هي
هتعمل الفرق بالاضافه الى
التدريب وانا بعتقد انه يعني ليبرد او
تشالنجر تو هي هتقدر تقدم نوع من القدره
المضافه للجانب الاوكراني خاصه من الناحيه
اللي هي هتكون خارج اقليم الدومباس او
محاوله خروج روسيا من اقليم الدومباس بعد
معركه ضخموت باتجاه كيف او باتجاه تقدر
تتحرك على هذه المساحه في الربيع المقبل
وده اللي بيتم الرهان عليه في تطوير
العمليات من الجانب الاوكراني الاخرى
بالنسبه
هذا هذا
يعني الان سنتابع معك اسمح لي ان تبقى معي
ولكن الان سنتحدث عن سوق الاسلحه وخاصه
سوق الاسلحه الروسيه ومن ثم اعود اليك اذا
مشاهدينا مع دوران عجله الحرب يبدو ان
مصائب قوم عند قوم مزيد من الفوائد وهنا
نتحدث عن الضرر الذي لحق بصناعه الاسلحه
الروسيه والفائده التي جنتها دول اخرى اذا
الحرب في اوكرانيا قدمت جزءا من حصه روسيا
في سوق السلاح العالمي مع بحث عملاء
لموسكو عن مورد اخر للسلاح لطالما كانت
روسيا هي اكبر مصدر للاسلحه في العالم بعد
الولايات المتحده الا ان نسبتها عالميا
انخفضت من 22% الى 16 في المئه كما نتابع
فرنسا احدى الدول المستفيده من مشاكل
روسيا لترتفع الحصه الفرنسيه من صادرات
الاسلحه العالميه من سبعه الى
11% صربيا حليفه روسيا اعلنت الشهر الماضي
اجراء محادثات مع شركه دسو الفرنسيه لشراء
مقاتلات من طراز رافال بسبب صعوبه الحصول
على قطع غيار للاسطول الصربي الحالي روسي
الصنع ايضا الفلبين بدورها الغى الطلبا
لشراء سته عشره مروحيه نقل روسيه من طراز
17 في الاشهر التي تلت بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا البديل بالنسبه للفلبين جاء من
الولايات المتحده بشراء اثنتين مروحيه من
طراز بلاك هوك في ايضا بدات تبتعد عن
الاسلحه الروسيه بعدما كانت معظم وارداتها
من السلاح تاتي من روسيا وباشرت منذ اعوام
قليله توقيع عقود لشراء بعض المعدات
الامريكيه بما في ذلك طائرات الاستطلاع من
دون طيار اذا التراجع في صادرات السلاح
الروسي لدول لم يمنع زيادته لدول اخرى
مثلا بحسب مسؤول عسكري روسيه يقول بان
ارتفع الاهتمام بالاسلحه الروسيه من دول
في افريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه الميزه التي
تحتفظ بها الاسلحه الروسيه عن نظيرتها
الغربيه السعر مثلا دبابه كليو بارد 2
الالمانيه يقترب سعرها من 11 مليون دولار
بينما يقول سعر دبابه تي 90 الروسيه عن
نصف هذا السعر ايضا اعود مره جديده لضيفنا
من القاهره استاذ احمد عليبه الباحث في
وحده الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه الاستراتيجيه
لنتحدث عن تداعيات استاذ احمد انكماش هذه
السوق الروسيه
للاسلحه يعني هل يمكن ان نقول بان روسيا
فقدت مركزها في سوق الاسلحه العالمي
بالتاكيد هذه حقيقه يعني حتى قبل ان تبدا
الحرب بوفقا للارقام اللي حضرتك عرضتيها
في التقرير والصادره مؤخرا عن معهد استقال
او تقرير صبري هي بتوضح هذه الارقام بشكل
دقيق لانه
كون ان هي تتراجع حصتها من السوق العالمي
من 22 ل 16%
قبل او في لحظه انطلاق الحرب كان متاثره
في حقيقه الامر بقانون كاستا الامريكي
الصادر في العام 2017
الفارق حوالي 6% بيمثل 31% من اجمال هذه
الصادرات لكن عندما اندلعت الحرب بدا
التفاهم او التراجع يتزايد عن هذا المعدل
بشكل كبير على سبيل المثال روسيا خسرت اهم
سبع موردين لها في سبع مستوردين منها في
العالم على راسهم الهند
والصين ومصر
ايضا بعض الدول الموجوده في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط واللي كانت حصتها بتمثل تقريبا
حوالي 36% من
من اجمالي المبيعات الروسيه واللي قسم
المبيعات الروسي في وزاره الدفاع بيؤكد
على انه هذا الحصه ايضا سوف تنخفض بمعدل
تقريبا يصل الى 26% جديد وبالتالي هي يعني
خسرت بشكل كبير جدا والخسائر مركبه لان هي
هناك زياده في الطلب المحلي وطلب المحلي
بسبب الحرب
بيفرض عليها ان هي تفضل في حاله انتاج بل
وتزيد الانتاج بمعدلات
الضعف بالنسبه للاسلحه هل سيتاثر او
سيتاثر جوده هذه الاسلحه يعني كما قلنا في
التقرير امريكا اللاتينيه افريقيا هي التي
اصبحت السوق الان بالنسبه لروسيا هل ان
نتحدث عن جوده متوسطه وس عر اقل من اجل ان
تبيع اسلحتها
يعني بالتاكيد الجوده هتتاثر في بعض
الاسلحه لكن لما نيجي نشوف هي هتتاثر من
اي ناحيه التقديرات الغربيه بتشير الى انه
في حوالي 450 مكون كانت بتحصل عليهم روسيا
من الدول الغربيه وده بيحصل فيه معظم
الدول يعني هذا ليس مختصر على روسيا لكن
التاثير الكبير هيكون بالنسبه
او الرقاق الالكترونيه هو ده هيكون
التاثير الكبير بالنسبه لروسيا واللي
الحقيقه الامر هي فرضت او وضعت ميزانيه
حوالي 44 مليار
عام 2030 علشان تقدر تعوض هذه المشكله لكن
في حياه الامر هي ما عندهاش البنيه علشان
تقدر تعمل دواء تلجه الى الصين كبديل ايضا
لهذا الامر وبالتالي الجوده فيما يتعلق
بالمسائل الاخرى زي العدسات او زي يعني
بعض
او الحواسيب انا اعتقد انه هي ربما يكون
الجوده او المتغير هنا ان هي تنتقل من
الجوده الغربيه الى الجوده الصناعيه وانا
اعتقد انه الصين الى حد كبير ربما طورت
ايضا في هذا يعني في هذه المنتجات بشكل
كبير لانه هي عندها طلب ايضا في الوقت
نفسه على هذه
المنتجات اللي هتحتاجها لكن ايضا لا
افريقيا ولا امريكا اللاتينيه
على
الاسلحه اللي هي الدقيقه للغايه يعني تاثر
على صناعه صواريخ قوام الى ذلك ولكن يعني
احتياجات افريقيا مثلا بتكلم على المسبعه
عشر او كذا واصبح في مخزون لانه زي حضرتك
ما ذكرتي مثلا ان الفلبين كانت طالبه 16
طياره فهتروح هناك كان في طلب ايضا على
السوق 24 هتروح لايران وما الى ذلك
وبالتالي لسه في ستوك تقدر تاخذ منه بعض
الاسواق اللي هي محتاجه
للجانب الروسي لكنها محدوده وانا اعتقد ان
روسيا فقدت الكثير من هذه الحصص بسبب هذه
الحرب ودي خساره مركبه بالنسبه لها تضاف
الى المكاسب ايضا المركبه لصالح القوى
الغربيه شكرا
من القاهره البحث في وحده الدراسات
الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
اعلنت كاسلين هيكس النائب الاول لوزير
الدفاع الامريكيه انا واشنطن تعتزم وانفاق
اكثر من 30 مليار دولار على شراء الذخيره
في السنه الماليه المقبله اي بزياده 12%
عن السنه التي تسبقها كما اعلنت الوزاره
انها ستشتري اربعه وعشرين صاروخ فرد صوتي
العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
افادت لجنه امميه بان كلا من الامم
المتحده والنظام السوري واجهات اخرى تتحمل
مسؤوليه تاخر وصول المساعدات للسوريين بعد
الزلزال واشددت اللجنه وعلى ضروره تسليم
المساعدات بحياديه ومن دون عوائق كما وصفت
طريقه معامله محتجزين في مخيمات سوريه
بانها ترقى لجريمه حرب
لقد فشلوا في تسهيل ايصال المساعدات كانت
هناك مناقشات واجتماعات خلال سبعه ايام
ولم يتلقى معظم الضحايا اي دعم لقد فشلوا
في تقديم الدعم الدولي في حالات الطوارئ
بما في ذلك الفرق التي تم انقاذها
والمعدات في الاسبوع الاول الحيوي بعد
الزلزال شعر السوريون بالتخلي والاهمال من
قبل اولئك الذين يفترض بهم حمايتهم في اشد
حالات الياس في عصرهم
[موسيقى]
في المغرب انتقدت ديوان الملكي حزب
العداله والتنميه لتدخله في السياسات
الخارجيه ووصف الديوان بيانا صادرا عن
الحزب بشان العلاقات مع اسرائيل بانه غير
موضوعي وفيه مغالطات كثيره عادل الزبير
معه التفاصيل
اعتبر الديوان الملكي في المغرب ان حزب
العداله والتنميه اصدر بيانا تضمن تجاوزات
غير مسؤوله ومغالطات خطيره عن علاقات
المغرب مع اسرائيل وربطها بالتطورات في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله انعلم جميعا
وقع القضيه الفلسطينيه على وجدان المغاربه
وهي تاتي في نفس المرتبات قضيه الوحده
الترابيه وبالتالي فان قوه ديون سياسيه من
خلال عشر سنوات اعجاب تحاول اللعب على
عواطف المغاربه من خلال مزايده بقضيه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي لا يمكن استغلال
التحولات الاقليميه للمزايده بهدف عوده
انتخابيا او سياسويا الديوان الملكي في
المغرب اوضح ان القضيه الفلسطينيه من
اولويات السياسه الخارجيه للعاهل المغربي
الملك محمد السادس بالارض الملك تجهز
العداله والتنميه حيال التطورات ديال
القضيه الفلسطينيه يعبر عن انزعاج واضح من
خلال البلاغ ولغته من المواقف التي تعبر
عليها حزب العداله والتنميه عشر سنوات من
التدبير في الحكومه للعداله والتنميه
ومشاركه اكثر من 14 وزير وكون رئيس حكومه
سابق سعد الدين العثماني وزير الخارجيه في
لحظه من اللحظات تقتضي ان يفهم ان المخطط
والذي يراس
للخارجيه هو ملك البلاد في رساله مباشره
الى اخوان المغرب اعتبر الديوان الملكي
المغربي ان مواقف الرباط لا تخدع
للمزايدات السياسيه او للحملات الانتخابيه
الضيقه فيما العداله والتنميه طالب قيادته
وقواعده بعدم التعليق باي شكل من الاشكال
تكراره هجوم حزب العداله والتنميه المعارض
على الدبلوماسيه المغربيه على خلفيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه دفع بحسب مراقبين
السلطات المغربيه الى اصدار بيان شديد
الله جه يوضح مواقف الرباط من القضيه
الفلسطينيه ويوضح طبيعه استئناف العلاقات
المغربيه الاسرائيليه عادل الزبير العربيه
الرباط
اعلن رئيس مجلس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني التوصل الى اتفاق ينهي الخلافه
بين بغداد واربيل حول ايرادات نفط اقليم
كردستان ووضع الايرادات من نفط الاقليم في
احد المصارف وبحساب واحد
ولله الحمد خرجنا باتفاق
شامل
حول القضايا التي
تمثل مشاكل عالقه بين بغداد واربيل لاول
مره
يتم التوصل الى اتفاق
بان
يتم ايداع الايرادات الكليه
للنفط المنتج من حقول الاقليم في حساب
مصرفي واحد تودع فيه جميع الايرادات
المتاتيه من تصدير او بيع النفط الخام
ومشتقاته بدون اي استقطاعات لاي غرض كان
ويخول رئيس مجلس وزراء الاقليم او من
يخونه بصلاحيه الصرف ويخضع الحساب المذكور
لرقابه الحكومه الاتحاديه وتغلق كافه
الحسابات المماثله الاخرى
في العربيه 360 نتابع بعد قليل موسكو تبري
اوكاز من تفجير نورد ستريم لانها تريد
متهما اخر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا القومي في البيت
الابيض جيكسراليا ستشتري ثلاثه غواصات
امريكيه تعمل بالدفع النووي من طراز
لرجينيا مع احتمال ان تشتري اثنتين اخرى
انه من المفترض تسليم الغواصات اعتبارا من
العام 2030 في اطار الشراكه الامنيه
الثلاثيه الجديده اوكوس بين الولايات
المتحده واستراليا وبريطانيا كما كشفت
واشنطن عن اتفاق ثلاثي لتطوير جيل جديد من
الغواصات
للمزيد حول تفاصيل هذا الاجتماع الذي عقد
اليوم من واشنطن ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
في ارغان اهلا بك معنا ماذا لدينا من
تفاصيل حول هذا الاجتماع والاتفاقيات التي
حصلت خاصه فيما يخص الغواصات
الرئيس الامريكيه وصل الانا الى
كاليفورنيا وسوف يجتمع بعد قليل مع رئيس
وزراء بريطانيا ورئيسه وزراء استراليا
سيكون هذا الاجتماع عمليا قمه
للاحتفال بالتوصل الى اتفاق نهائي حول ما
يعرف بالقوس وهذا الاتفاق هو حلف ثلاثي
انجلوساكسوني اي يجمع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبريطانيا واسرائيل وكله وكل
هذه الدول تتحدث اللغه الانجليزيه
وللدخول في مشروع طويل المدى جيك سالفين
تحدث على انه اتفاق على مدى قرن كامل
ونبدا اولا بمشروع الغواصات ولكنه يذهب
ابعد من ذلك يذهب الى ان تصبح استراليا
حليف كامل في بناء قوه عسكريه دقيقه
وعاليه التقنيه مثل الغواصات من نوع
فرجينيا فهي غوا تسير بالقوه النوويه
وتستطيع ايضا ان تطلق صواريخ نوويه
وتستطيع ان تبقى تحت الماء لفتره طويله
جدا الجميع يريد ان يقول بما فيهم سالفا
ان هذا ليس موجها ضد الصين ولكن بالنسبه
للعالم بما فيه الامريكيون يعتبرون ان هذا
الحلم هو محاوله لاحتواء الصين ومنعها من
التوسع بالنسبه لمراجعه الدفاع والسياسه
الخارجيه التي تم تحديثها في اعقاب الحرب
الاوكرانيه فير هل تم الحديث او هل هناك
اي معلومات رشحت عن هذا الموضوع
اعتقد انك تتحدثين عن السياسه البريطانيه
الامريكيون عندما تحدثوا عن هذا الموضوع
اعتبروا ان اي زياده في المصروف العسكري
والامني الاوروبي وغير الاوروبي هو امر
جيد لان ليس من مسؤوليه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تتحمل الاعباء الماليه
للتصاعد العسكري والمخاطر العسكريه اكلت
ظاهره من روسيا او من قبل الصين بدون شك
انها الامريكيين سعداء جدا
بالزياده في هذه الميزانيه العسكريه
البريطانيه
شكرا لك من واشنطن مراسل العربيه بشار
غانم على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
انتهى حفل الاوسكار الخامس والتسعين على
جمله من المفاجات جعلت الاحتفالات تمتد
حتى الهند وماليزيا لتين حقيقتا جوائز
نادره في المسابقه الاهم في السينما
العالميه لكن المفاجاه الاكبر كانت في
فيلم
والذي اكتسح اغلب الجوائز رغم ان نقادا
شككوا اصلا في امكان وصفه بالفيلم رغم عدم
الاختلاف على جودته
[موسيقى]
جوائز اوسكار لعام 2023
فيلم
الرابح الاكبر بسبع جوائز منها
وافضل اخراج لمخرجي الفيلم دانيال كوان
ودانييل
افضل ممثله ميشيليو
فاضل
لجميع الاولاد والبنات الصغار الذين
يشبهونني ويشاهدون الليله هذه مناره للامل
والامكانيات هذا دليل على ان الاحلام
تتحقق
افضل ممثله في دور المساعد جيميلي كيرتس
تم ترشيح والدتي ووالدي لجوائز اوسكار في
فئات مختلفه سابقا والليله فزت اخيرا
[موسيقى]
افضل ممثل في دور ثانوي
امي تبلغ من العمر 84 عاما وهي في المنزل
تشاهد امي لقد فزت بوسكار
اما جائزه افضل ممثل فذهبت البرندن فريزر
عن فيلم
[تصفيق]
بدات في هذا العمل منذ 30 عاما ولم تكن
الامور سهله بالنسبه لي واريد فقط ان اقول
لكم شكرا على هذا التقدير
من الدمام ينضم الى الكاتب والناقد
للسينمائيه طارق الخواجه استس طارق اهلا
بك معنا اولا هل تفاجات بهذه النتائج في
الاوسكار
مرحبا مساء الخير اي نعم اعتقد انه هو
مفاجاه
لكثير من المهتمين بالشان السينمائيه خاصه
نحن كنا نقول انه
يعني
دخوله اصلا
كان غريبا لكن الاوسكار منذ سنوات وهو
يفاجئنا وكذلك معايير التقييم اصبحت
مختلفه بهذه النقطه البعض يعتبر بانه
نتائج الاوسكار هذه السنه اتت وكانه
الاكاديميه تحاول ان تزيل عنها صبغه
العنصريه التي اتهمت فيها منذ سنوات هل
هذا وارد
هو طبعا يعني هذا ليس مقترحا هذه حقيقه
يعني منذ سنوات
الاكاديميه الامريكيه
تعدل بشكل كبير جدا في المعايير هناك الان
معايير تصنف الافلام بدرجات حتى تصل لدرجه
الاف مثلا
للافلام التي فيها تنوع عرقي الافلام التي
تناقش قضايا الصوابية السياسيه الموجوده
في امريكا افلام التي تعتني كثيرا
بالهويات المتعدده وهذا اعتقد جزء طبيعي
من التغير اللي حصل ويبدو واضحا يعني هم
حاولوا حتى على صعيد جوائز مختلفه منذ
السنوات الماضيه وهناك تغييرات واضحه لكن
السنه هذه كان اعتقد هي النسخه الاكثر
نكهه اذا صاحب تعبير المرتبطه بالتغييرات
التي اصبحت تتضح بشكل كبير جدا ثم يتعلق
بمعايير الاكاديميه الامريكيه طيب عن اي
معايير بدانا نتحدث الان يعني
البعض اعتبروا انه يعني هو لديه جوده في
العمل ولكن يعني لم يعتبروه بانه فيلما
سينمائيا كالافلام التي كانت تصل الى هذه
الاكاديميه او الافلام التي تحصد جوائز عن
اي معايير بدانا نتحدث الان
نعم هو يعني انت اذا نظرتي للمعايير
المصنفه في الافلام السينمائيه وخاصه
الاوسكار يحتفي خليني اقول بافضل
الانتاجات الموجوده داخل السنه
يعني مثلا فيلم كل شيء هادي على الجبهه
الغربيه
قام باخراج مثلا او على سبيل المثال الذي
قامت ببطولته يعني هذا الافلام هي القريبه
جدا من مزاج الجوائز في مثلا
بنشوف انشر مثلا هذا كان متوقع انه يكون
له حظ كبير جدا
وهو حاصل على جائزه في افضل طويل لكن مثل
ما يعني هناك تغييرات واضحه جدا في
المعايير التي يرغب عن الافلام تنتبه لها
بشكل كبير جدا واعتقد انه في السنوات
الماضيه كان في جدل كبير جدا مرتبط باعمال
تعتبر مهمه جدا ولكنها خرجت فارغه اليدين
اذا صح التعبير او خاليه الوفاه فاعتقد
انه نعم نحن نتحدث عن معايير متغيره
باستمرار هناك واضح بشكل اساسي ان انا
مقبلون على افلام ربما لا تنتمي لقضاء
الكلام السينمائيه التي يعترف بها في
الجوائز او في المهرجانات السينمائيه التي
يتم
تعني كثيرا من شان الجوده السينمائيه يعني
العمل على الفيلم وكانه عمل استثنائي لكن
اعتبار تغيير المعايير هو الى الاحسن الى
الافضل
لا بدون شك ضمن الاسوء يعني واعتذر عن
القسوه هذه لكن اذا اصبح النظر الى الى
المخرج السينمائي والمنتج السينمائي خارج
ما يتوقع بين يكون هو المعيار الحقيقي في
تقييم الفيلم والذهاب الى المرتبط بايجاد
تنوع عرقي والنظر الى الصوابيه السياسيه
والانتباه بشكل كبير جدا للمساواه وكل
التفاصيل هذه وكان الفيلم اقرب الى كتاب
يعني خليني اقول في الحقوق او في القوانين
التي تعتمدها
المجتمعات في شان التعايش السلمي والتفاهم
الاكبر بين السكان الفيلم السينمائي فيلم
عمل ابداعي وعمل تعبير يقوم به كاتب يصل
لفكره هذه لمخرج المخرج يحقق رؤية معينه
تقوم عليها مؤسسه الانتاج ولذلك اعتقد انه
هذا سيدفع المؤسسات الانتاج الانتباه
كثيرا لهذه المعايير وهذا كله على حساب
الجوده السينمائيه يعني على كل حال ايضا
حتى فيلم نافالني كان هناك
الكرملين قال بانه ايضا هذا فيلم وهذه
الجوائز فيها الكثير من التسييس واتهمه
الاكاديميه بذلك والسينما الامريكيه اشكرك
استاذ طارق الخواجه الكاتب والنقد
السينمائي على المشاركه معنا في 360
[موسيقى]
فيديو اليوم في العربيه 360 من المكسيك
مهما ارتفعت الجدران على الحدود ستبقى
مسيرات المهاجرين على حالها مكسيكيون
وفنزويليون وغيرهم يحملون ما خف وزنه مع
اطفالهم سعيا للعبور الى ارض الاحلام تنجح
السلطات وانفاذ القانون في التصدي لهذه
الموجه الجديده ويدور حوار المعتاد
امنحونا الفرصه كي نعبر كي نصنع مستقبلا
لنا ولعائلاتنا ويرد رجل الامن لا نستطيع
تعلم انه صادق ويعلم اكثر انها صادقه
وفي تصريح اليوم واوكرانيا ليس لديها
الامكانيه للقيام بهجوم الارهابي كالهجوم
على خطوط نودس ريما التصريح او سقوا
البراءه ركاب هو من نيكولا باتروشيف مجلس
الامن القومي الروسي لكنها براءه لان
موسكو تبحث عن متهم اكبر والحديث هنا عن
واشنطن ولندن وفي كل الاحوال فان عملا
كهذا في راي فتره لن يتم من دون موافقه
الدوله التي تعط الاوامر في حلف الناتو
والمقصود بالطبع الولايات المتحده
اما صوره اليوم من بخاخ موت يطلق الجندي
الاوكراني قذيفه مدفعيه بل مدفع الهوت زور
هاتفا باسم الرئيس الاوكراني جوزلينسكي
اقصد فولوديميرزلين من اجل الشعب الامريكي
اقصد الاوكراني من اجل هزيمه خصمنا
التاريخ روسيا اقصد من اجل ارضنا واطفالنا
لماذا هذا الارتباك نعم الجندي الاوكراني
لكن كل شيء في الصوره عليه ختم اخر امريكي
الى هنا تنتهي العربيه 360